is true yeah i think it's just the way
that society is now though because
they're trying to normalize a lot of
things and they're trying to normalize
like
trying like trans women trans men like
yeah and where where like nowadays we
can't even
speak to some and say like she or she
was like
yeah i mean
i was still cool
yeah like unless they get offended
whatever but it's like sometimes
nowadays you have to be wear full of
stuff like that yeah that's how society
is that site is starting to construct
this way for us to think yeah we have to
be whip like yeah wary of things like
that that's why
yeah that's why it's hard to just say
like no she can't compete you know i
mean yeah
it's like almost like we're program like
i don't think it's natural because i
like i feel like a lot of people like
listening to me because i'm like no
that's not real
and it's kind of like like a lot of
times when i say something like like i
feel like people are like programmed to
be like politically correct you don't
want to offend anyone i will say that
it's true yeah
you don't you're like this is it and
this is it i remember the first time
that i came on the podcast with you i
was like oh
[Music]
that's perfectly fine
um
it's just i feel like
there's certain things in society
that
we have made like
touchy subjects it's like
don't we cannot talk about this because
it's
you don't wanna you don't wanna say the
wrong thing and it's just like but what
if i'm just expressing my opinion can is
my opinion wrong if it's not agreeable
to yours and i think that's
when it comes to when it comes to that
side of the
lgbtq plus community
i think that that's one of the touchy
places and correct me if i'm wrong on
that because i don't i don't claim to be
the network of all that
so yeah well it's almost like there's
certain even like race like it's a
touchy subject too yeah like there's
just certain subjects and i think it's
like lgpt
lg
the lg you know yeah
like like right like there's just
certain subjects that i feel like people
can't speak freely about because they
don't want to like be canceled or like
say the wrong thing yeah and i feel like
if
if it wasn't like that so many so much
more so many more people would be
educated on
other people's
lives and how they operate and be able
to express themselves and if they don't
agree they don't agree and
we were going to have their opinions
it's just
you want to be if you're not if you're
not on the
right side you're not respectful
and
it's just like why
why yeah
because there is it's like my opinion my
opinion
and when i say my opinion it's not to be
disrespectful but that's just
you know what that's how it is you know
it's also crazy i feel like
i think um
it's unfortunate because i think most
people don't have really strong opinions
either way
yeah you know i mean i think most people
are kind of in the middle but it's
almost like in order to stop stuff like
this you have to be loud like if i'm not
in the us right now but if i was like
there were very few things i would
protest for one yeah bring back plastic
straws that would be my first protest
i would i would march the stream
bump them
but this is like the second thing
because i just
i have never been like so much in an
athlete's like shoot like because i can
like i can just feel yeah how that would
feel like like
if i was sitting behind someone that was
trans oh my i oh i would be so mad
i can't even imagine i don't know if i
would have competed
honestly i don't know if i would have
been yeah they should have protested
everyone should have sat out if they was
well i don't know if they're really
against it though they haven't spoken
out i feel like that they have to be
there's no way